we've got breaking news for you I have
to tell you the pictures are shocking
from London today where Julian Assange
is long standoff with international
authorities is finally over this is
Julian Assange he is 47 British police
removed the WikiLeaks founder from
Ecuador's Embassy this morning clearly
he did not want to go he's been inside
since August 2012 hiding from a UK
arrest warrant Assange his lawyer says
the arrest follows a u.s. extradition
request WikiLeaks says Ecuador's
decision to allow police to arrest
Asajj violated international laws in
tias ty Abbas outside the embassy in
London MT has good morning
good morning well a very dramatic scene
here outside of the Ecuadorian Embassy
really the end of a seven-year standoff
between Asajj and British authorities
British authorities who quickly swept in
and took him into custody after the
diplomatic protection that he was
receiving from the Ecuadorian
authorities was revoked here's how it
all unfolded
heavily bearded and handcuffs the
WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange was
dragged out of the Ecuadorian Embassy by
British police shouting the UK must
resist his arrest is seven years in the
making the 47 year old had been wanted
by British police since 2012 when he
skipped bail and sought asylum at the
Embassy to escape extradition to Sweden
on accusations of rape and sexual
assault Swedish prosecutors dropped
their investigations but the WikiLeaks
founder told his supporters from the
embassy balcony that he still couldn't
risk leaving the UK and that's exactly
what happened his fear now as then is
that the u.s. government will request
his extradition on charges of espionage
WikiLeaks has provoked the US government
for more than a decade leaking troubs of
classified documents and videos online
in the 2016 presidential campaign came
more leads thousands of emails hacked
from prominent Democrats US intelligence
agencies later concluded Russia had
delivered the data to WikiLeaks in an
effort to discredit Hillary Clinton a
charge Assange has denied but in 2017
he said his self-imposed exile
and challenging in almost five years
here in this embassy without sunlight
seven is without charge why my children
grew up without the UK's Home Secretary
Sajid Javid has confirmed that Assange
is in police custody and that he will be
in front of the judge very soon
adding and I quote no one is above the
law
Gail that certainly seems to be the case
today I still can't get over those
pictures mts hi AB reporting from London
this morning thank you very much